[Musique]
64 ans aujourd'hui je suis combien
donner rendez-vous les girondins depuis
l'âge de 10 ans j'aidais ma mère avant
d'aller à l'école et vous êtes installés
ici alors elle a pris si le kiosque en
1921 je l'aidais depuis cette époque là
ici aussi on reste de prendre trois
champs elysées et oui combien allez-vous
de journaux par une moyenne de 17 à 18
cents alors le kiosque est ouvert de 6h
du matin à 1h du matin il s'agisse que
de vous demander combien gagnez-vous
l'arrêt goûter ils nous font une remise
brut à peu près de 18% mais on paye 25
francs qui vous voulez un journal que
l'on entende
c'est ce que vous auriez une anecdote à
nous conter depuis son occupation alors
là j'étais un petit peu dans le bain et
j'ai beau temps c'est vous dire que j'ai
servi de bouée collecte et il est passé
quelques kilos de plastique n'est passé
plus de wii alors liban terme apporter
ça dans l'est parisien
zitouni décharger départ isère et dont
j'avais une vingtaine de kilos de
plastique et vous en recherche ont
scandé à bas j'avais l'organisation tête
qui occupait tout l'immeuble en face
tout 33 et ça donne un peu plus de huit
ans
nous
[Musique]
qui
keller j'avais vous madame geoffrin de
14 y'a combien d'années que vous êtes
ici poule var saint germain erreur
vous savez qu'on va vous changer les
kiosques le vote d'adt de quelle année
dès 1890
vous avez connu beaucoup de
personnalités ici il paraît que vous
avez père connu poincaré oui vraiment
vraiment oui oui qui avez vous connu
encore et emblème gelé sur ni le général
du bug qui me demandait alors mon
putting quel poison allez vous ne donnez
aujourd'hui quel âge aviez-vous à ce
moment là
[Musique]
il